58.7% FROM FISCAL YEAR 2021 TO
2022.
>> Todd: BORDER CRISIS TOP OF
MIND IN FLORIDA, NUMBER OF
MIGRANTS SKYROCKETED 129% IN THE
PAST TWO YEARS.
FLORIDA AG ASHLEY MOODY JOINS ME
NOW.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE, HOW
MUCH IS THE BORDER CRISIS
IMPACTING THE VOTE THIS YEAR,
CAUSING DEMOCRATS TO SAY I DO
NOT LIKE THE DEMOCRATIC
POLICIES, I'M VOTING REPUBLICAN
>> Ashley: I HEARD BIDEN MENTION
THIS WEEK, HE SAID THERE IS SO
MUCH AT STAKE, THE ECONOMIY,
PERSONAL FREEDOM, ARE YOU MAKING
THE ARGUMENT FOR CONTINUING
GREAT LEADERSHIP IN FLORIDA FOR
US?
THESE ARE THINGS TOP OF MIND.
YOU SAY SAFETY OF THE STREETS,
LET ME TELL YOU WHERE THAT
STARTS, SECURING THE NATION'S
BORDER, MAKING SURE YOUR
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT
DISASEMBLING THE STRUCTURE IN
PLACE TO HAVE SAFETY AND PUBLIC
SAFETY IMMIGRATION LAWS ENFORCED
THERE.
NOW SEEING RECORD HIGH AMOUNTS
OF FENTANYL FLOODING OUR
STREETS.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE OPEN
BORDERS AND SINCE BIDEN TOOK
OFFICE, NUMBERS ARE
ASTRONOMICAL, FIVE BILLION
PEOPLE WE KNOW OF HAVE TRIED TO
ILLEGALLY ENTER THE U.S., MORE
THAN THE POPULATION IN HALF THE
STATES, MORE KNOW THAT THE
POPULATION IN 100 COUNTRIES AND
TERRITORIES ACROSS THE GLOBE.
BECAUSE OF THESE POLICIES, BIDEN
HAS TURNED INTO THE TRAFFICKER
IN CHIEF, WE SEE INCREASE IN
HUMAN SMUGGLING, TRAFFICKING,
DRUG TRAFFICKING.
WHEN TALKING ABOUT SAFETY OF OUR
STREETS, YOU HAVE TO START WITH
THE BORDER AND IT IS LAUGHABLE
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY AND PERSONAL FREEDOM,
HAVE THEY NOT BEEN PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE LAST TWO YEARS,
FLORIDA KEEPS OUR EYE ON THE
BALL AND WANT RIGHT FOR
CITIZENS.
I SAID, DO YOUR JOB, KEEP YOUR
HEAD DOWN, WORK HARD, PROTECT
RIGHTS OF CITIZENS AND SAFETY
AND THE REST WILL TAKE CARE OF
ITSELF.
>> Todd: FLORIDA POLLING, YOU,
RUBIO, DESANTIS, CONTINUE TO
LEAD, WHAT MESSAGE ARE FLORIDA
VOTERS SENDING TO THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY?
>> Ashley: FLORIDA CONTINUES TO
STAND OUT AS A STATE, IF YOU
CONCENTRATE ON DETAILS, MAKE
PEOPLE SAFE IN THEIR STATE AND
BE PROACTIVE AND PROTECT NOT
JUST THEIR RIGHTS AND SAFETY,
YOU ARE PUSHING WASHINGTON OUT
OF OUR ABILITY TO LEAD THE STATE
THE WAY OUR CITIZENS WANT TO BE
LED AND THE WAY THEY WANT TO
LIVE THEIR LIVES.
HALF MY JOB AS ATTORNEY GENERAL
IS PUSHING NONSENSE OUT OF
WASHINGTON WHEN THEY TRY TO CRAM
IT DOWN INTO OUR STATE.
THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
ELECTION, WE DON'T AGREE ON
MOST, I WILL AGREE WITH BIDEN,
THIS IS IMPORTANT ELECTION FOR
THE REASONS HE SAID, KEEP
FLORIDA, FLORIDA.
KEEP BEING THE BLAG BEARER FOR
THIS NATION AND THE WORLD,
SHINING EXAMPLE OF WHAT YOU CAN
DO WHEN YOU STAY FOCUSED AND SEE
SUCCESS.
IT HAS BEEN A TOUGH COUPLE OF
YEARS, EVERYONE WOULD ADMIT, WE
ARE SEEING PEOPLE MOVE HERE IN
GREAT NUMBERS AND GREAT
PROSPERI